صحيفه البريطانيه نشرت تحقيقا حول نواحي
سلبيه للذكاء الاصطناعي في المجال
التعليمي ببريطانيا التقت صحيفه بيطالب
يبلغ من العمر 16 عاما استعان بمساعده
زميل دراسه الجديد بالذكاء الاصطناعي عبر
هذه المساعده تمكن من انشاء بحث مصغر حول
حياه مصممه بريطانيه وكانت بعض المعلومات
الوارده في البحث غير مذكوره في اي مكان
على الانترنت استطلاع اخر اجرته صحيفه
فارسيتي الطلابيه بجامعه الشهر الماضي
اظهر ان ما يقرب من النصف الطلاب قد
استخدموا تشات جي بي تي لاكمال دراستهم
20% من الطلاب استعانوا بهذه الاداه
للحصول على درجاتهم العلميه بينما خطط
السبعه في المئه لاستخدامها في الاختبارات
للغش في سويسرا كشف معهد روزنبرغ سويسري
عن ان الثلاثين في المئه من الدرجات في
المعهد تم الحصول عليها باستخدام الذكاء
الاصطناعي ورغم السلبيات يصعب ترجيح كفتها
على الايجابيات بحسب تقرير فاينانتشيل
تايمز رغم انه يصعب ذلك لكن الصحيفه طرح
التساؤلا حول ما اذا كان من الممكن فتح
الباب امام الذكاء الاصطناعي في التعليم
دون المساس باهم ميزات التعلم البشريه
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات